as men were not meant to walk around
wearing off our emotions on our sleeves
all the time much less letting our
motions get the better of us stoicism is
a very much a lost virtue but that's how
men are supposed to behave we're
supposed to carry the burdens of life
and of providing for our families and
all that kind of stuff carry it with a
certain dignity and certainly not
looking for pity from people and as is
indicated here there's like nothing that
women find less attractive than someone
who's pouting self-pity from a man is
probably the least attractive thing to a
woman because it's the it's the exact
opposite of what she needs and wants